protesters are gathering at the New York
State Capitol today to fight a bill to
end religious exemptions for vaccines
all but three states allow religious
exemptions as a reason not to vaccinate
children there are 839 confirmed measles
cases across the country so far this
year the disease had been declared
eliminated in the u.s. in 2000 dr. Jon
LaPook
is at the State Capitol in Albany John
good morning good morning John protests
us here expected to claim that
legislators are attacking their
religious freedom but in Orthodox Jewish
communities where these measles
outbreaks have been occurring we spoke
with rabbis who told us there's
absolutely nothing in the Jewish
religion that prohibits vaccinations
meanwhile we're learning about a group
that's been spreading misinformation I
think this has been a long time in
coming dr. patricia rupert is the health
commissioner of Rockland County New York
Ground Zero of the current outbreak
there have been 225 measles cases
confirmed there since October
but Rupert is certain the real number is
much higher the truth is there are a lot
of unreported cases out there Rupert
says misinformation is fueling the rise
in cases especially within the county's
Orthodox Jewish community have you heard
of an organization called peach I have
for at least the last four years what's
come to be known as the peach pamphlet
has been circulating in the northeast
targeting Orthodox Jewish communities it
holds a lot of unscientific and
erroneous information the pamphlet
incorrectly claims vaccines are a
contributing factor in causing autism
the overwhelming consensus of the
scientific community is that vaccines do
not cause autism any idea of who's
behind it no I've wondered that myself
so we tried to find out the pamphlets
cover says it is a project of parents
educating and advocating for children's
health or peach that organizations
website posted a statement saying it had
nothing to do with the pamphlet even
though it hosted a copy on its website
until last month when the pamphlet was
taken down
the website lists one address in
Brooklyn so we went but all we found was
this windowless concrete building we
found a second address in the company
business records but when our team
knocked on the door nobody there knew
anything about peach there's an
organization named peach that's actually
registered as being at this address
doesn't sound familiar the peach
pamphlet lists several hotlines to call
for more information
so we did welcome to the truth about
vaccines there was a lot to listen to
but it was far from the truth
there is a role that vaccines are
playing in creating the groundwork for
their these children's immune systems to
start to show signs of impaired
destruction these people make up data
they change their reasoning as soon as
it's disproven and they pick another
wacom all right exactly dr. Aaron GLAAD
is an infectious disease specialist and
an Orthodox rabbi in Woodmere New York
you must get vaccinated on Sunday at his
temple he lectured about the safety and
effectiveness of vaccines and held a
testing event to check people's blood
for evidence of immunity how did you
hear about this peach publication I've
known about them for a number of years
some of the religious information they
provide is embarrassing do you think
it's gonna take for people in the United
States deaths before they really pay
attention I hope the answer to that is
no but part of me says yes I literally
pray that I'm not proven right because
there's deaths and people then switch
their opinion CBS News obtained
anonymous text messages like this one
sent last month to Orthodox Jewish
fathers in Brooklyn while they were in
Temple when we called the number
provided in the text another misleading
statement this vaccine will cause
swelling of the brain they all do every
single vaccine causes encephalitis
dr. Rupert has been scrambling to fight
the false information in Rockland County
about vaccines what we've done in these
months was to offer information in other
ways hangers on the doors pamphlets in
the synagogue's
Flitz up the house so in a way you're
fighting low-tech with low-tech yes we
are
amid the community's rising fear dr.
Rupert is doing whatever she can to
control the outbreak in a typical year
Rockland County gives about 1,200
measles vaccines since October
they've administered more than 20,000
thank you looking back has there been
enough pressure put by public health
officials by the media on the
anti-vaccine movement no I don't think
we have provided the pressure that we
should have probably all along do you
think going forward there has to be more
of a concerted effort I do and I would
be glad to join with others who are
doing the same the peach organization
would not speak with us on the record we
learned yesterday that peach has changed
its name but it continues to say it
promotes education and children's safety
meanwhile here in Albany we're expecting
later in the day to hear a lot more
about protests and lobbying of the
legislators gale alright Jon LaPook
thank you very much John thanks to you
and the CBS News investigative team for
trying to track this down I feel like no
community is being specifically targeted
with misinformation whether there should
be a criminal investigation or not is a
question for prosecutors but I find it
really disturbing they obviously know
the information they're passing is bad
because they're hiding yes they're
exactly as we tried to find behind them
yeah I raised a lot of interesting
issues that people should be demanding
answers to NORs right about that